au grand théâtre chaque métier a son
propre tempo
quand les affine les réglages du
prochain opéra d'autres s'attèle déjà le
suivant dans la salle dite des choeurs
les sopranos et des altos s'activent au
programme devant jack massenet et la
tasca quand le coeur devient un
personnage à part entière l'aider à
s'harmoniser sa couleur d'ensemble c'est
l'un des rôles d' alexandre herviant le
jeune chef de choeur landais
nouvellement arrivé à tours il faut
qu'on rassemble un peu le berger c'est
un effectif assez réduit finalement ce
qu'on se retrouve à 13 chanteurs donc
c'est en moyenne entre trois et quatre
chanteurs par voie donc c'est vraiment
un coeur un choeur de chambre ce qu'on
peut appeler un choeur de chambre
ça présente vraiment là davantage de
pouvoir faire un vrai travail de fond
très très très très précis très
exigeants comme coeur aussi
changement d'étagé petit ou dans la
salle de danse
maintenant c'est le tour qui fait que du
coup ça fait sept séances position là
les artistes construisent leur
chorégraphie pas à pas on commence à
bord nous et puis après on enchaîne donc
on voit déjà l'espace avec le décor et
puis à prendre ajoute les costumes et
puis après on rajoute les perruques à
chaque fois il ya un élément nouveau qui
nous donne aussi le temps de nous
adapter à chaque fois pour
l'aboutissement final nous retrouvons
nos danseurs sur le plateau ils seront
bientôt rejoints par les autres artistes
pour une première répétition générale
avec cette fois-ci costumes et orchestre
le tout sous l'oeil attentif du nouveau
directeur des lieux
lui qui entend s'appuyer sur les atouts
de l'équipement tourangeau on a la
chance puisqu'on n'a pas de soliste
permanent de pouvoir inviter des
artistes
donc certains qui sont sur les plus
grandes scènes internationales et puis
aussi des artistes plus jeunes et on
pouvoir mélanger un petit peu ces
expériences différentes
sait on a moins de contraintes
apparemment que dans un dans une très
très grande maison type opéra national
et avec des enjeux plus importants
puisqu'on est le seul le seul outil
régional
l'énorme machinerie s'ébranle avec la
précision d'une horloge suisse dans
cette subtile mécanique où chaque pièce
tenir sa place regling millimétré
solistes choristes danseurs musiciens et
techniciens nous offre éblouissement et
l'émotion
[Musique]